from here I think we want to go to this
the lowish here singing so so someone
like me who likes the idea of mastering
the language for example in a classroom
setting I mean again I appreciate what
you're saying in terms of listening to
stories so then at what point do you
introduce a formal grammar syntax if
there's as I say somewhere like me who
likes to master the language late
greater greater your familiarity with
the language the better the sense you
have with the language the more
situations you have encountered with the
language the more the explanations will
make sense oh yeah I've seen that okay
now I understand oh and then you'll pick
up a few that you hadn't noticed oh yeah
okay right now I get that okay that's
how it works but when you have zero or
very limited exposure or feeling for the
language the grammar explanations are
just I really believe it relatively
meaningless and if you're if you're
focused on trying to remember them or
get it right as you say master that I
personally can't master like we can get
better and better and better
we'll never get perfect in another
language but we can continue to improve
and I and and you know what I would do
then and I'm not yet that state at that
stage in my Russian because I ever start
gonna go back to the grammar book as I
forget it but I would if someone were to
do me and record for me a simple rush if
such a thing is possible Russian grammar
in Russia then I would use it as
learning content to quote finish up or
master my but I would do it in Russian I
don't want to hear the explanation in
English because all the time that I
spent reading English is to me a waste
of time from the perspective of learning
Russian
it was a little a stuff time but I admit
that I still don't understand English I
mean this really gets back because I
think the way they've been teaching
grammar up until now it's been really
it's been a linguistic model teaching so
it's subject and predicate those are
very high level advanced concepts and
what I wanted to kind of remove that
from people and say okay listen here are
the basic essentials that you need to
know if you know the basic parts of
speech you can learn another language
and view